oh for [ __ ] sake
the dog
[Music]
oh jesus christ
i i don't know why people do this why is
it always short guys
doing box jumps it's not gonna make you
taller mate out of all places
you could have done that in the gym
right in the middle of the floor
excellent this is just someone
trying to enlarge their penis size some
people do it out of the gym with a range
rover this guy is trying to do it
with box jumps in the gym
just bent in half those two bits of
equipment probably are not designed to
be used together
uh probably hurt quite a lot pretty sure
he kicked himself in the back of the
head on the way through that
for [ __ ] sake no
no no no no where's the practical
application for this for a start
gone in there for a consult hello mate
love to be great at leapfrogging
feel like there's not enough resistance
when i go for a run
what on earth this bloke as a trainer
i put out a reward for finding him this
is dog
oh bear calls yeah the the missing
ingredient of
most people's workout regime he's making
this up
he's making this up
idiots someone's going to see that oh
where do i sign up for personal training
that's why people like me have got a bad
name that and sleeping with too many of
their clients but mostly that
[Music]
oh jesus christ
he could have just broken his neck and
for what how'd you break your neck while
i was i was just trying to do a backflip
with some dumbbells what
because the backflip wasn't hard enough
there is no purpose for this
[ __ ] what on earth
do we have here michael phelps
working on that stroke this is certainly
freestyle isn't it
i've never seen this bit of equipment
used like this before
literally a fish out of water an idiot
out water
here we go another wannabe athlete
different shoelaces
alarm bells already red flags ready
set pretend you're at the olympics
oh got one was coming from if you're
gonna do something in the gym
maybe test it you know get the bungee
cord give it a bit of a yank
probably he's probably gonna say too
much power you know probably gave it too
much
oh oh he's giving that given that bench
good time
let's get someone's getting ready for
the weekend it reminds me of will from
the in-betweeners
that is um an interesting way for users
in a seated row
innovative say the very least when maybe
when the leg press is always busy that's
your go-to
i'm not quite sure what to say but
they're probably gonna need to
reupholster the leather on that
after what he's just done to it
why have we got here
welcome to england when people in
australia say what's the uk like
i'll show them i'll show them this
welcome to england
jesus christ it's like a roller coaster
ride
the dog the dog
is that that would that be in five
seconds sooner
probably in the end of the dog if you
are thinking of training at home
over locked down covered quarantine
do not need this bit of equipment and if
you do have that bit of equipment
i'd recommend you get on it sober
you